[Music]
they are we will be talking about the
machine learning approach that we used a
[ __ ] to optimize prices during
clearance sales and I will give you some
tips on how to implement data science
into into business first of all as Santi
already said I'm a physicist either I'm
a C and PT on physical oceanography so
I've basically been studying a long long
time series and doing some predictive
modeling during the past years and I
joined mango early this year to apply
this knowledge of predictive tools and
predictive algorithms to to the business
so the contents of this talk will be
first of all we'll talk a little bit
about mango I'm pretty sure there's any
really big in tradition pretty much you
all know the company but I will explain
the advanced analytics department what
we do there then we'll talk about retail
in general so we have an immense amount
of data any retailer does and how to
work with the data in how to actually
implement the data into the
decision-making that's extremely
difficult and it's key nowadays I will
present a use case I will talk about the
algorithm that we use to predict which
is the optimal price during sales season
for each item of the collection and I
will give you some tools or well some
tips about what we learn in the process
so mango it's a pretty huge company
basically these are data from 2017 but
we are present in more than a hundred
countries we have revenue in 2018 of 2.2
billion euros so it's it's pretty pretty
huge
the important thing here is a mango it's
familiar company it started as a small
business and it started to grow so it's
possible to you know you need to think
first a small and then big and it
happens the same in data science or in
the engineering you need to start small
and start building things and you can
create something huge as mango for
instance some data some some dates we're
free old business we started our
business in 1984 with the first shop
here in Barcelona it was kind of long
time ago and the interesting fact here
is in 2000 we opened our online selling
portal so it's basically almost 20 years
since we are a business that combines
both worlds offline and online and this
give us this omni-channel experience of
the client and we are we always try to
think of the client as a whole not only
online not only offline but both walls
together and that's also something that
in data science you need to to have in
mind because things are not individual
but things normally go together here it
ends in 2017 but in 2018 the advanced
analytics department was created mango
of course had old business OPI takeaway
platform and in department it has a huge
that were warehouse platform and all
they are reporting and dashboard aware
created from the from the deckhouse
platform and so because of course from
2000 there was an online portal so all
the information and records and
everything it's it's safety our platform
but it doesn't expire is trying to go a
step further it's not only about bi it's
about giving or giving the support to
the company to make
in decisions making informed decisions
so we are trying to achieve a data drive
an organization and we're trying to
improve the company through machine
learning as well through Y so where are
we right now right now we are in the
point of trying to create or creating
this big data platform this big data
platform is it's it's like we have the
old data warehouse platform so we are
trying to implement these data into the
big data platform so we have the right
base from which we can start building a
data science team to be able to obtain
information and to apply the models you
need to have the right base the right
plan for you cannot create a team or you
cannot obtain real value from the data
creating or building something vertical
you need to be aware that first you need
a good base and then you need to start
creating and this is what Mangal is
doing Mango last year in 2018 started
the advanced analytics department we are
five people only so it's a small team
that has this base on on top of this
base layer so we can grow on top and
this is basic for any organization to
have a good base to start creating and
building bringing the information and
the data to the business retail in
retail we have whole universe of data we
have millions of data until the data for
instance we are having a TCP P of a few
thousands of gigabytes per day so it's
it's pretty enormous but we also have
internal data basically we are saving
things like the tickets or the sales
from the stores the stocks that we have
the the transport systems the there's a
lot of later that is safe right there
the transactions for instance but we
also have on Salesforce we have the
marketing cloud we also have the Google
Analytics from our website that we are
using bigquery to to query we also have
our own Oracle database that we store
all the things like the feeds and so on
we also have the information from the
feed finder and we also have the smart
wardrobe information so there's still a
lot of information that can be stored in
our database and that we need to to
query and we need to you know get value
from how to do that how do you actually
decide where to put your focus where to
ask the questions or which questions
should be answered
basically there are three key words that
I think will bring you that information
first of all the initiatives that you
that you do has to be hot to be
actionable they have to be measurable
and they have to have a real business
impact why because if you don't put the
focus on these types of fractions you
will not bring value and confidence into
the business again you need to build a
really strong base and then start
building from there it started small but
start in a you know continuous base so
do not try to build the Eiffel Tower the
first day first learn how to to a house
then a village and so on
so this is what they need to be done or
at least is what we have learned that it
works so our use case I'm going to
present here the marketing optimization
model for the sales season
it's called - this project was meant to
find the optimal price to maximize
project profit sorry
after all it for each product so
basically the question that we like to
answer is which is the optimal discount
during the sales season why this project
why this one and not any other one first
of all it was actionable we had all the
data in the right place and we know
where the data was so we could actually
query the data it was miserable because
we were able to do an a/b testing to
measure the success of the project and
and it had a real impact because it
increased the mean profitability during
sales season so that's something the
first stream power but not only that -
not only affected the revenue that of
course it does
but you also have these three and
complete vision of the process there is
give support and it's a support and it's
a tool that the project managers can use
to take informed decisions so they know
which is the optimal price so that they
that half the field knowledge can take a
better decision and it also has
knowledge because the project helped to
help to build knowledge of the of a unit
and brought to the stakeholders the
confidence that the advanced analytics
department could do machine learning
approaches and can take you know bring
data into the top level how have we
achieved that so first of all we
prepared the data we though we did all
the data preparations and insight so we
obtained the recent purchases stocks by
its elasticity shops for instance and
all the variables so first you need to
find the variables are right and then
you need to measure the variable
importance from your model then we
bought we both the machine learning
algorithm
using a random forest basically we train
test and if prediction using the
variables from historical historical
data and then the press optimization
that was like the biggest challenge okay
so you have a prediction based on the
historical record for its product but
how do you find which is the most
optimal price we created a matrix with
all the possible price points that are
eaten can have for each week during the
clearance sales so we gave a prediction
a forecast prediction for that Eaton
price for each week so once you've got
the prediction you can calculate the
margin after all it the profit for each
particular case and then if you rank the
matching you can find which is the
optimal price for that item so I'm gonna
explain that in more detail because it's
be you know tricky basically we created
a combination like these so this table
is a combination of IDs this combination
of price point it's this is an ID ID one
ID 255 IV 1241 IV 2219 and so on right
combination number one is the lowest
possible prices so 499 for each quick
combination number two will be $5.99 the
first week 499 the second week 499 to
total one combination 255 its 1799 the
first week
$15.99 the same the second week it's so
on right and these are three cases that
I will show now on the next slide this
is the same table that we had it was
eight weeks but I just cut it into four
just to remember the the table okay and
this is the theoretical margin for each
combination of price points for each
model so the the curve the red curve
is one model one item okay
the yellow one is another one and the
blue one is another item so three
different items with all the three of
those have the same table right like
this so what we did is use the machine
learning algorithm that we built before
to give a prediction of sales based on
those prices so if you if we consider
item the red item it's here right for
the combination of price with number
seven
so it would be something like $7.99
$5.99 and so on
has a margin of X euros whatever it's
really cheap so you sale everything in
the first two weeks and then you don't
have any left over another combination
another possible combination is for
instance 500 and you get more margin
because you are selling more but also
you're having more left over which is
the optimal combination the optimal
combination is that that gives you sales
so this case a minute n and you've got
10 of left over but gives you the
maximum arching so basically for each
prediction for each forecast you will
have a margin for the possible
combinations I'm not sure if that was
clear but if you have any questions like
me ask you can ask me later so the
challenge the mathematical challenge was
there to find the optimization but we
also had to measure how do you measure
the success of this project to measure
we did an a/b testing using the legacy
method that was how they put prices on
on the past was basically a person that
knows the field of project manager was
taking the decisions and analyzing all
the data and putting the prices for each
item and the new method was using - and
to give
pre-created lessor prices to the same
person or to the equivalent person of
the country and they can take the
decision based on the data that we
already give them so based on the data
we measure the I'm not quite sure if you
know how to measure the results of an AV
testing we used a difference of
differences approach it's a really easy
method statistical it's not really it's
no it's really difficult but it's
significant so basically you well this
is supposed to be a heroic map no
question why it's not you cannot really
see it but okay we've got different
countries which we were implemented the
methods and we divided all our items in
different families
what we did was compare the results
obtained in one country or another it
divides for instance in one zone and
another son so did two different
countries we used the legacy method for
the families a and the new minus method
for the families a in the in the in the
other area the difference between the
results in so the probability that we
obtained on a versus B was the 3% so we
performed three percent better in zone 2
learning zone for families a in four
families be there are shirts and skirts
the - method and the legacy method
perform equally but we had third family
so dressed jacket jeans rhetoric and
leather that we applied the - method on
those two areas so basically you have
like a liar so we have a way to see
what's the difference between zones
using the same method d vs f perform -
super sense to be perform to two percent
better than f
that means that the difference between
these two are always the same
so basically you got a 3% here four
families are a but you need to rest
these 2% that perform different so
you've got an impact of real impact of
minus of 1% here they look like they
perform the same but they didn't because
they know that the difference between
zones are minus 2 so basically is this
one it's au plus 2 because remember we
are changing here right - is here or
here so we've got an impact of minus of
2% so if we did the mean of those we've
got a mean impact of 1.5% these are of
course just examples of data but you see
there's a way to actually measure the
success of the project
once you have action the project and
obtain a significant impact like in this
case you need to focus on how to scale
it it's really important you keep in
mind that you not only need to measure
because you need to have a number it's
really important to measure because you
need to understand the dynamics that are
applying on your project so when you
scale it because it's gonna happen it's
always going to happen you need to
understand how to scale it properly you
need to again build a good base and take
the decisions that will help you grow on
top of that base do not try to grow fast
and vertically but create a good base
and then start from there what have we
learned what tips can I give you
especially if you're starting a small
project and you are just trying to
showcase what you can do with E AI or
machine learning first of all your code
be prepared for the future because now
you're maybe in a small team you're by
yourself writing code then it's like
yeah I'm gonna
try to do something and I'm doing the
experiment but then you will start you
know writing more and more code and
somehow you end up like with 20,000
lines of code and you need to scale that
or give that to someone else or so on
and it's a mess it's a completeness so
remember be flexible utilize use
parameterize parametrizations use
variables because do not heart code
anything because data changes because
parameters changing because changes
because assumptions sometimes changes so
keep that in mind when you write your
code make it scalable at least try to
keep that in mind because you will have
it to scale it scale it if it works and
please recommend everything because
you're not alone and be really really
organized these are best practices that
are basic for any project in data
science so for instance use kit it's
really important to be really organized
on the versions that you're using and be
able to reproduce the coding the in the
past in the future sorry it's extremely
helpful sometimes interpretability is
key do not focus on precision okay it's
not really important if you obtain an
accuracy of 0.7 T or 0.7 to 1% what is
really important is to get the job done
you will always have to make assumptions
I mean it's not that you it's like I
need to put in production and extreme
difficulty learning algorithm deep
learning that I don't really understand
but I want to use it no just remember
try to use the tools that give you the
that you feel more comfortable with and
that you can understand well okay try to
get the job done that's the most
important part of it and if you cannot
explain what your algorithm does you
will have a big
why because one you will not be aware of
the assumptions that you were making or
the limitation that you have and two no
one will understand what you are
actually doing if you cannot communicate
your resource to the stakeholders you
will lose their confidence they will not
believe what the results are so if you
doubt use the grammar principle if you
cannot explain it to your grandma if
your grandma cannot understand what you
are saying no one can trust me um Tim a
solo mission is a suicide mission
I mean it's impossible to do things
alone
so surround yourself with the diverse
team not only in gender but in
background and experience because a
diverse team will give you a different
approach to the same problem so if you
can approach a problem from different
perspective you will most likely have a
better solution and you will probably
gain the solution in a faster in a
smarter way
what problem do we have with data
science one of the main problems that we
have that we want to do modeling we want
to do modeling and we don't really care
about the data no it's ok it's ok it's
not ok you need good engineers to help
you with infrastructure you need a good
base in which create things on top to
build models on top of that and of
course be really really aware of your
needs there's a huge big data ecosystem
you can use ass or you can use Amazon
Web Services you can put a spark on top
with data breaks or without data breaks
and then you can also whether you use
clove era or whether you put this a lot
of fuzzy walls let's use other power you
mean what what it means to use for the
Blitz but be aware of our needs it's
extremely important because it doesn't
it's not about the tools it's about how
do you use the right tools for the right
problem I really like these cue disco
that says you can have data with our
information but you cannot have
information without data and for me it's
extremely true information is really
really really key because if you don't
have the information if you don't have
the knowledge to take them from
decisions you can have a lot of data but
you have nothing right
so just final remarks we really need to
take inform decisions because knowledge
is key it's extremely important to bring
not only the data but the knowledge that
comes from data to the business there
are a lot of opportunities to sit in the
business decision making there's a ton
of rooms for growth and to develop IV
tools but it's really important that our
projects are actionable measurable and
that has an impact because otherwise in
the long run we will not succeed so keep
that in mind if you want to be able to
create a good project thank you so much
and just a quick note on that we are
hiring as everybody else in the world
but actually I'm really looking for
someone to give me a hand on creating
that to bring the model into into the
big data science platform so I'm really
looking for someone that has knowledge
of spark and can develop tools on a big
data ecosystem so if you are any of
those people just give me a call or well
pick me a message there and I will be
really happy to talk to you afterwards
thank you
thank you very much Carmen I very much
agree with you on the importance of
extracting the actionable knowledge from
the results of the data science that's
for me that's a big gap that we have to
research a lot on that because it's not
well solved it's not well it's not a
well methodology that helps to follow
this gap some of us are working on that
for years and but I think it's it's
really important that people like you
from the other side express this need to
stimulate the Academy to concentrate a
little bit more efforts on that point
also you have been talking about the a
batiste right and you were making like a
kind of to sample2 sample test
comparison right so my question is how
do you decide which is ona and Zone in
zombie I mean which kind of of criteria
are you using are they areas in the same
city or to guarantee the homogeneity on
the two on the two areas compared and to
be sure that that the differences are
about the treatment and not about other
kaveri Abele's there's a different ways
to approach it we've done these two
times and we have used different
approaches on on both basically one of
the times what we did it was of course
we don't want different prices on the
same country so basically what we've
done is find areas of one country owed
yeah one country with one country in
another country that are comparable in
terms of number of shops climate for
instance also revenue that we all tame
so the areas are comparable between them
that's one of the main things and we
have done that on different countries
not to have you know and and how is the
cultural context
we're all under because I guess that
when you are comparing areas in terms of
this kind of very objective a very
objective criteria the differences might
be not because of the method but because
of some other issues that rely do
something that you are not measuring in
fact I mean exactly
um you cannot have a totally comparable
area that's one of the limitations that
we have you are changing country right
especially even without within a country
I mean there's how do you have a sample
big enough to be representative and
significant but also to be exactly the
same as in another place for instance
imagine Russia if we divide Russia into
regions they are not comparable at all
but maybe but what we thought is okay
but let's try to find countries are more
or less similar especially within Europe
like France it's some house in Germany
you keep on the same kind of yeah same
region okay so they are more or less I
mean they are not going to be exactly
but at least they will be more similar
like it's not China with I don't know
with us a for instance but they are
close enough to be more or less similar
and the climate it's more or less
similar to because this is one of the
most challenging issues as well when it
is when you are talking about making
real tests of course it's extremely
complicated
for instance Italy in Portugal also
similar Spain in Portugal you know they
try to but you need also always to make
assumptions and you cannot say this is
the result and it's absolutely true
because nothing is absolutely true we
know thank you very much thank you hi I
also have a question regarding me
because think about before going on my
question I'd like to also and I was that
I'm also hiring so before you speak to
her maybe you can come to me I think I
offer something better
so I saw on your slide you were
comparing legacy with what you call - in
any B and C nevertheless in
in one of the groups you are not
comparing legacy unless I misunderstood
something yeah
so what were you comparing in see that's
the first question
I'm not taking question how did you
choose to target your audience for the
a/b test what what share of the traffic
and how did you make sure to not have do
not over cross the audience okay so
basically how do we decide from Alesi we
try a and B that we're the group test to
be a similar list on as possible but we
didn't want to do the test on all the
families so we are resting impact to the
test so we're trying basically to find
20% of our families or models to be the
target of the test and then the a/b
testing were done on both platforms
offline and online for different
countries so basically we were choosing
just about the countries related with a
previous question not about just
audience but the country from which it's
come from hey hi thanks for the talk I'm
curious about the previous section where
you specify that you created a random
forest or predicting sales I have
various questions but one understand
basically you put different prices and
you have the home price points yeah how
did you come up with those numbers
that's it the universe of price points
is something that it's common for the
whole mango company so we have a
universe created universe of price
points also you cannot pull any price
the price points are discrete okay and
then you predict sales on each of those
of those prices on the whole season at
the same time yeah so basically what we
do is predict the sales that we you you
will have when you put those prices and
then home ok so this relates to my
second question which is basically I
know you are more in the fast fashion
more not a hundred percent but your
items tend to change a lot how do you
tackle the costs our program
because you're gonna predict things
you're gonna predict you on top of
products that you've never seen in your
catalog what we predict because we are
predicting the sale season in the sales
season already has the season behind so
we have this Oracle data of this season
with the models are right now the shops
so we are not predicting something that
we don't know how it's going to work
with the client we already have that
knowledge because we are right now
selling the stuff so for instance the
next season the next sale season will be
in January so from August to December we
have the data of how this item has been
has been south did you try the time
series before trying random first
I guess you try different models but why
random forests in the end because it was
understandable because he gave us
results it was understandable and it was
easy to implement it was fast there's no
other reason we could change the random
forest we can change we could to choose
sorry a random forest so we could have
to another thing it works for me yeah
thank you yeah thank you have the same
question so the additional question was
what the loss function
have you used for the random forest
maybe it's custom functional loss
I mean square terror or I use accuracy
in the road mean square error yeah both
between because it depends on what we
were analyzing us the error of the of
the accuracy of the of the of the model
I used different approaches over the
time but mainly I think in the last
version it was a Punnett square just a
small comment when you say that random
forest is understandable in my in my in
my experience for me it's very easy to
understand a decision tree a single
decision tree when I have a random
forest I really feel a little bit lost
and understandability so at that point
how do you manage them the
interpretation of the random forest yeah
because
it's extremely true yeah I mean it's
like that I choose the random forest for
interpretability because it was complex
enough to translate the difficulty of
problem and to the stakeholders and also
because I can train something like that
with the variables so I can actually
tell in a visual way okay so this is
what we have these are our variables is
it's a really good way to communicate
and for me it helped it helped a lot I
agree with you it's not totally
understandable but at least being able
to show how the variables are related
between each other
helped me a lot but you must choose a
small subset of decision trees to do
that so you maximize those that are
performing better or something like that
okay thank
[Music]